thank you
[Music]
all right welcome to another awesome
episode of the careful boys and of
course we have a guest favorite hey
Jason Chinese
thank you so much for having me why do
you do it like that
it's fake it's announcing it thank you
for having me yes I don't say it like
that you just said it like play it back
dude you just said it like that man yeah
yeah do your precious JCPenney that was
a good like announcement like oh thank
you so much that was very nice like that
hey don't bulldoze me okay
before we get there what was your uh
first impression of everybody well I
tell you just go down the line start
with Bart start okay then you're gonna
tell don't look at me orgy story
yeah
you got it you're [ __ ] right in the
face
what's the first impression so it is
okay I'm gonna say it yeah orange is
innocent too if you do it all the time
okay so what's your first impression of
Bert but
one day Bart stronger Bart um you know
goes this way I I love because I I never
seen you do like I watched jko a long
time ago you know and then um I never
seen you do it live and it's really fun
to see all of you riff but it's really
fun to see you riff that because all of
you have like different style we just
met today too is the thing yeah all of
you guys have like we're talking about
bart
yeah but you said everybody so I'm just
doing the [ __ ] gumbo right now man
I'm doing a gumbo dude
's the gumbo low and slow all right yeah
man I'm doing a gumbo okay yeah keep
going keep going I love gumbo I love um
I like gumbo too yeah that's what I did
at gumbo I thought it was a combo
experience
oh you heard combo combo like he's
combining our names under the
experiences
okay good we're back we're back on track
now
so what was your first impression when
you met Bart for the first time Bart
um what that that was that was it it's
just I mean I feel like it's just the
whole vibe of the place it's just you
guys have a good time nice time who are
you immediately like I think I can
connect with that person and then who
are also like that person I would least
connect with uh what I knew Nick before
and he he's always so nice so nice you
know and then Ryan when I met for the
first time too he was also so nice what
in the process of elimination just me is
the least favorite that you connected
with Anthony's a little Brash you know
what I mean a little rough around the
edges
no you're also super nice to me too is
the thing for you everybody's also yeah
you're like really nice to me too isn't
it you know everybody is seriously yeah
seriously that that was my impression
I'm not yeah and you you like a lot of
the times sometimes like uh on the
article and then if I'm not saying stuff
you'll go oh what do you think and
that's like you include me and I really
appreciate that no because sometimes I
say that's so nice
that's so nice
thank you that's all I wanted no and
then you too is the thing I mean
everybody what's everybody's catchphrase
um okay you're that so nice
um yours is
Ryan's wild
action is about me Ryan you were wild or
whatever is the key word of the topic he
tries to make it into another word that
doesn't make any sense
Oh you mean
you
mean
Oh you mean like red Zyrtec
why does he have a smug laugh that's
board turkey turkey
and Borton Burt work okay so sometimes
it works sport is good
what else what else what's another
catchphrase
um Bart's catchphrase is obviously
something that nobody could ever predict
so it's not a catchphrase he always
comes at it just like right when Bart
always has a certain moment in a video
where he'll just say something and I go
wasn't seeing that coming at all and but
I'm glad he added to it because now it's
like now we're on a different path you
should this isn't Bart's catchphrase
musical catchphrase
like for instance when we were talking
about the Indonesia
um soccer game and he goes I'm gonna
find more floor to cover myself yeah
nobody would have seen that coming I
wouldn't have said that you know what I
mean that's good it's good Ryan Amaze is
just obviously the running gag is he
knows someone that died that's the
running guy that's the running gag he
says that every time
today today it's really funny hey I know
it I know a dead guy that said the same
thing
as in Colleen she just tip of the Hat
[Laughter]
she goes I
I agree with that sentiment and she goes
yes I agree with the sentiment and then
me obviously is I just I'm always
accepting of everything everybody and I
have unless I'm about you yeah you're
inclusive because it's not about me okay
no no no no no no no Nick Segways out of
things yeah you're good at that you're
gonna including can right candy here
like what's can's catchphrase I put them
on blast and bulldoze them like that
that didn't take me all right so it's
Joe's so right before you do Joe's the
best we'll get to this prompt uh we were
just talking about auditions because I
know a lot of us have been in uh on an
audition before and you said you had
some strange stories with Lady first oh
ladies first you said first for
auditions yeah any audition story
um the lady is going to choose Anthony
to talk about his um
experiences oh you got to do it then yep
you have to Bro experience it too Ryan's
wild
man I just want to straight back to me
right away huh yeah have you what have
you auditioned for
um are you talking about like acting or
is it are we talking well things I
wasn't that much who has the balls to
make you audition for dance though is
the real question well you know you have
to audition for like not Anthony Lee
okay
the leader of the kinjas he's not
bulldozing I'll tell you that sorry
sorry there was there was one audition
that I went I don't know if I told this
here before
um but uh so one time uh when I had just
gotten an agent uh I I you know when you
just get signed you're like I better
show up to all these auditions and I had
known that auditions weren't for me I'm
just not really that type of person for
people who do it it's like [ __ ] cool
I respect that I think that's like a
serious skill and stuff I'm not very
good at it and I just don't really like
that feeling as much
um just go in there and then just like
kind of the feeling of needing to of
course I think the idealism is just do
you but really it's like outperform
everyone
um and I just I'm not that kind of a
performer or dancer or anything like
that sometimes they have a direction
they're like oh it's not outperforming
but they're just like oh I don't like
this style but that style Maybe
yeah
so back to my story
um so uh so basically there's this time
where uh I got this call to come in uh
or a couple times I got a call for an
audition I was like I don't really like
that I don't realize so I didn't show up
and then my uh my agent was like Hey You
Gotta kind of shovel from [ __ ]
audition I was like yeah you're right
next time I'll go uh I'll go to the next
audition right and then you never know
when you're gonna get a call when you
get a call they're just like uh this
time this place you gotta wear this blah
blah this type of campaign can you make
it and it's always the assistant calls
you or emails you so can you make it and
you have to be like oh yes I can yes I
can't uh no I can't so finally
um I uh I wasn't ready to get an
audition it was just like a random
Thursday or some [ __ ] like that and uh
I'm um
forward man I'm a little nervous to tell
this for whatever reason uh we decided
to take shrooms that day oh [ __ ] micro
uh
no a full dose yeah
so close not a grand plus but like a
good dose like I'm I'm eating stems and
caps right oh no and then um why did you
guys have that idea why not did it take
shrooms Yeah Tuesday you know it's
because sometimes you just for an
audition no you don't know when you're
gonna get auditions sometimes your agent
just hits you up yeah yeah yeah it's
just like this audition right and I
skipped out on a bunch of auditions and
then finally we get I get hit up but I'm
already kind of like on shrooms and I
had already told them I was like yo like
I um
I I promise we'll go to the next one so
this is the next one oh [ __ ] so they
called me up and I was like oh [ __ ] oh
and they're like yeah you promised to go
the next one I was like oh [ __ ] okay
yeah I'm gonna go and they send me the
information and I checked the
information it's like we're business
casual right but when you're on shrooms
you don't know things the right way have
you taken Insurance before no has
anybody taken shoes so the bottom half
is business casual and the top is oh you
thought it was business casual well
right
I took it twice and both times I didn't
really feel anything explain to like a
general person what the effects of
shrooms are if you could explain that I
don't even know because I didn't even
feel it what about you nick uh when I
took it when I felt a nice effect was I
was in Zion
and I just felt very euphoric I felt
like my mood was definitely elevated
more than usual and I just felt like I
don't want to say it makes you happy but
there's like a you just feel a little
bit more light and then I feel like
perspective wise you're thinking about
things a little bit differently than you
normally would if you were so
open-minded yeah you're a little bit
more yeah a little more optimistic a
little more open-minded how long does it
take to wear off and when you realize
you're not in Zion
and I was like holy [ __ ] yeah in the
office
whoa
you're just in Buca di Beppo oh yeah
yeah I would say I would say a place I
would say another way to describe it uh
is like you feel like a child yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's a good way to
explain it maybe that's why it doesn't
work I would like so yeah maybe that's
why people always yeah so like when
you're a kid and you're interested in
curious in something you like that might
take up your whole world even if it's
really small yeah
um and and you just have a joy you have
a curiosity you want to explore things
if something else distracts you you're
something like oh that's shiny that's
cool and you kind of just go off as well
right so I get called in for this
audition my dumbass is like oh I have to
go because I said I would go even though
I'm on [ __ ] drugs
um and then uh it says business casual
suddenly I don't know how to dress
business casual yeah and that's your
house describe business casual because
how would a kid know that if you're in
child like Wonder I would think
um probably
slacks right you have to wear a dress
shirt you have to be tucked in but you
not necessarily have to have a tie right
maybe a blazer
um
and show a little skin independent
absolutely right so that makes perfect
sense it's very Basics very simple my
dumbass decides like oh dude this is
casual what should I wear I go get a
maroon v-neck
I get these like uh suede uh olive green
pants that are cuffed at the bottom fire
I put on leather boat shoes and I wear a
Navy twill uh blazer with leather uh
elbow pads and I think to myself I'm
schnazzy that's like the word yeah this
was named Fonzworth Bentley or whatever
yeah like not appropriate for the
regular type of business casual business
casual if you're businesses you work at
I don't know Barnes and Noble yeah maybe
maybe but for this type of like
corporate business casual they're
looking for exactly what bars right like
a stock broker guy exactly like we're
talking too far off I think the colors
might be a little he was a little more
artistic I haven't thought of that you
think it's not too far off right until
you show up and the thing that they were
casting for and remember they're casting
for a particular type of look they're
looking for an Asian American you know
what I mean like XM x height blah blah
business casual like Harold yeah so when
I walk into this room
there's 12 or 13 other Asian dudes that
look exactly like me yeah that are
wearing the exact same business casual
like a dress shirt tucked in tie all
around the same exact look and I'm the
guy in both shoes and like a v-neck are
you still have shrooms but she stood out
though so when I walk in and you see and
think about like this there's only so
many Asians that look the same that get
casted for this type of role right when
you're saying guys you see exactly
you're seeing the same type of it's like
you're walking in and looking at
yourself so imagine being on drugs and
seeing like 10 or 13 other oh [ __ ] yeah
at the same time right and I started
tripping the [ __ ] out right and this is
for a cell phone I think it was for
Samsung at the time right and then uh
like literally the first thing I do
right obviously everyone's already
staring at me and when everybody's
staring at you you're already paranoid
yeah but whenever it's actually looking
at you it's a whole other level of like
you're like all right and then the lady
gives me a [ __ ] sign-in sheet to fill
out same thing I never ever [ __ ] had
to write anything ever on streams before
right oh wow I was writing like it was
my off hand like it looked like a kid
was trying to [ __ ] put letters
together they were going through it bro
I was just going through it right and
then here's here's how bad I'm going
through it right after that I see a
homie who like I haven't seen in years
and he's also auditioning for the role
and he's like yo Anthony I'm like trying
to keep myself composed so I'm like
what's up man and he's also on troops
but he looks just like me I'm looking at
a mirror right at a sober me then they
called me and I go [ __ ] just audition
the guy's having me hit my markers like
you know take a photo here stand with
the product here hit this Mark stand by
the tape blah blah look up say this one
and the guys who's trying to direct me
to do basic stuff but I'm like it's not
a real self one he gives me he's giving
me a styrofoam block so when he gets you
can stop I like kind of laugh
I think it's fun
silly oh man you know that's not a
building that's just the green screen
directing that I'd cast you immediately
except the guy halfway through he's like
dude this is your first audition and he
was [ __ ] annoyed because I couldn't I
was not positive I'm not gonna look and
be like dude I want shrooms those
casting people can be dicks too they
could just be default [ __ ] too by
the time I get out of this thing because
shrooms is also this thing of like
Euphoria too when you're when you're
finally back in a safe space it like you
really I feel feel good right so after
being in that I was so [ __ ] up I get
back to my car and when I'm like away
from everybody else so I finally get
back to my car and I start hysterically
cracking up that's so funny it's so dumb
that I just did that and had to go
through such a weird experience looking
at like 13 other Asian guys that looked
just like me going for the cell phone
role on a styrofoam block and I was just
on the streams looking like an idiot I
look like an idiot so you got the part
no dude that'd be awesome if you got it
you showed up to set sober and they're
like what happened you used to be so
chill everybody
just Segways into Anthony and his drug
use over the years you can't he can't
perform
[Laughter]
it no but I will say though that was my
last audition ever I just after that
after that I was just like because then
all those copies of you gave you the
idea to start kinjas no [ __ ]
exactly was that a dance or was that
acting audition that wasn't a dance at
all that was purely like I would love to
see the footage of that [ __ ] yeah when
the agent's just like do you want to
just do this what type of roles do you
look for and I was like at the end of
the day I'm like whatever you think like
oh you're an Asian person you're down to
act I'm like yeah I'm down to act you
know you're a nation person have you
ever filmed yourself on shrooms and
watched it back when you were sober no
that would be hilarious because it's
like what you think is happening and
then what's actually happening and then
to cross-reference that and see if that
was actually the case you did it uh no
we had a uh we so we had this JK trip we
were went out to Vegas and
um we all smoked in the hotel room and
then we decided to watch Tropic Thunder
but before we were going to watch Tropic
Thunder we're like oh this would be
great we should record ourselves
so we I remember setting up the camera
and then we're like oh we have to
there's like maybe like
four or the six of us inside the room
we're like we have to push the beds
together so we pushed the beds together
and then it's one of the guys was like
oh [ __ ] I think like the smoke is
leaving the room it's gonna [ __ ]
they're gonna be on to us and then we're
like no we're done smoking we haven't we
haven't there is no smoke in the room
and so the whole time we're like most of
us are watching uh the the movie the
other dude was rolling up towels and
stuff in the bottom of the door class
yeah the whole time and then I remember
laying there and uh watching the movie
and going this is the most boring movie
I've ever seen in my life and I [ __ ]
love Tropic Thunder because I just
remember the intro where it has like
that like old school like military style
like like classic rock music and then
the helicopter like just flying through
the jungle I was like how long are they
gonna hold on the shot dude what the
[ __ ] man it doesn't smell like forever
wait you love the movie but you're
watching it high and didn't like it all
hated it we all had the same sentiment
that sounds like you're watching
Apocalypse Now yeah we're all watching
it we all hated it there's a dude stuff
in the [ __ ] towels at the bottom of
the of the door he was killing the vibe
dude yeah and then we I watched I
re-watched it and it just
how intense the room felt when you
watched the actual video it just looks
like a guy like
like the most boring like security it
became that wow I mean watching us
operate in the room oh I know what's
crazy in your head yeah because in your
head you're like dude is this movie
[ __ ] work oh yes so what like it just
seems like really big and then when you
watch the video it's like
this is kind of boring huh that's really
boring like that oh wow yeah the
reactions are way lower than this idea
was it to film yourself watching
tropical it's a good idea it was mine
because we used my laptop
because one of my buddies he he like
micro doses a little bit here and there
and sometimes he'll be like hey man
sorry if I was being weird earlier you
know I was I was I was streaming a
little bit and I was like you weren't
being weird at all you were being
completely normal didn't notice a thing
but like whenever you do those drugs
you're always so [ __ ] deep in your
own head that you think like oh my God
I'm probably being such an idiot right
now but in reality you're just the guy
moving the Zyrtec bottle you know it is
like that though like even when I was
driving to that audition I knew that it
was regretful because when I got in my
car and I was in traffic the lane was
breathing and moving right so in my
world I was looking at the freeway and
like this was happening on the freedom I
was like this is the [ __ ] craziest
thing but I bet you the guy next to me
is looking at me and he's just seeing
the guy who's like super focused yeah
probably yeah yeah you know what I mean
like nothing's actually happening do
that with your hands again
that's pretty cool thank you this expert
dude if you want to know a funny
audition thing when I first started
auditioning which was like early
um early 2000s like 2007. I went in for
like one of those like Blockbuster
auditions where it's just your head and
you're just talking and then they
[ __ ] asked me to do it in a Chinese
accent
how did you do it just randomly show us
right now well because first they were
like you know it's you got to be cool
tell them like you know written videos
is cool like it's one of those things
yeah and then after I did it they were
like okay now do it like um like Asian
more Asian I was like more Asian how'd
you do it and I was like I was like
going to a Filipino accent they were
like no no no like Chinese
I was like dude I'm not gonna [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] yeah and then I [ __ ] did it
anyway
do you think it was pretty good yeah I
felt like a [ __ ] [ __ ] I literally
was like oh you know video is so cool
random videos like this
sellout dude yeah and then and then I
walked out that was that was your
Chinese accent yeah really [ __ ] up and
then I walked out and then really [ __ ]
up and then my other friend who's also
not Chinese it's like am I gonna have to
do that [ __ ]
foreign